everything ends even the brightest
bonfire will fade to embers we've all
seen that before
embers holding on to a fragile flame you
had a life before this there was a woman
a home a child a curse your woman your
home your child right what happened to
them
you don't remember what you do remember
is the curse you struggle against it but
it consumes you and you experience death
and in death you dream you dream of a
lost kingdom a murky forgotten land a
place where Souls may mend your ailing
mind then you live once again
who were you before you died when did
you get to this forest doesn't matter
push on but you're tired so tired now
all you remember is that your memory is
fading but wasn't there something else
there were important memories they were
everything to you
now they've melted away and you're
organized by their loss your aggrieved
by this curse and so you throw away
everything you used to be and gain a new
purpose discover the origins of the
curse and use the legendary souls of
drangleic to maintain your sanity but
soon you realize you're not the only one
who journeyed to drangleic with this
goal drangleic once drangleic was a
mighty Kingdom led by a wise king and a
mighty queen but Giants from a far-off
land waged war with the kingdom to
reclaim something that was stolen from
them
the Giants were repelled but the
weakened kingdoms soon fell victim to
the curse of the undead hollowed
soldiers overcame the lands and the king
who once had the strength to lead his
people also found the strength to fight
them but something went wrong the king
has locked himself away and no one has
seen the Queen the kingdom of drangleic
is in decay everything will crumble and
waste away so that something new may be
born drangleic it bears resemblance to a
place we once knew a world with struggle
between light and dark a kingdom with a
sinner a king the doomed betrayer and a
mass of the dead a land where the curse
of men reflects the curse of the world
every flame turns to ashes kingdoms rise
and fall some light some dark all
struggling for new beginnings with a
fragile flame trying to survive among
the embers but perhaps struggling is the
fires ordinary step
the curse of life is the curse of want
and so you peer into the fog in hope of
answers this video was made slightly
better because of the 408 people who
kindled this channel if you're
interested in supporting this channel
and getting rewards like seeing videos
early then click the bonfire